Professor.
I didn't think I'd be talking to you again so soon after we saw your backyard
astronomy, but we've got breaking use in space.
You've been imaging it what's going on up there.
Yeah. It's not often that we get things happening, you know,
as stock presses we have for this particular event,
but there's been a supernova has gone off in Messiaen 61.
So one of our messier objects has put you on a show at the moment.
No, there are different types of supernova. What's this particular one.
This is a type two supernova,
which means that when you split the light of it up into a spectrum,
you find the absorption lines of hydrogen in the spectrum.
So what this is telling you is that whatever is exploding,
you're seeing through a lot of hydrogen.
So the hydrogen is kind of obscuring a bit of the explosion and absorbing some
of the light. And that tells you that what you're looking at is a massive star,
which still has all its sort of outer layers of hydrogen on it.
So there's an explosion going on in the core of this star that we're seeing
through the outer layers of hydrogen of the star itself.
So it still had lots of fuel in the tank, sort of.
It has fuel. And some of it will still be actually physically bound to the star.
Some of it,
it will have blown out into space in the late stages of its lifetime. Um,
but yes,
most doors end up with a lot of their hydrogen leftover before they blow up.
Okay. So can you talk me through what a type two supernova actually is?
What happened to this elevated star sitting there and M 61?
So this is a store right at the end of its life.
It's a lot more massive than the sun is at least eight times the mass of the
sun. And it's gone through all the nuclear fuel burning stages,
turning hydrogen into helium, into carbon,
into all the heavier elements it's run out of fuel.
And the nuclear fusion is really what holds the star up. You know,
the pull of gravity is trying to pull it in, was on itself.
And the nuclear reactions in the center are generating the energy necessary to
hold it up against gravity. When you run out of those reactions,
the whole thing just collapses down and ends up imploding.
Essentially the whole star collapses down, uh, onto the center of,
of where the star used to be.
You end up forming a neutron star right at the center.
As everything gets very compressed,
the star then sort of bounces off that neutron star flings its outer layers out,
turns out that's not quite the whole story.
That's not enough to make the star explode completely.
But the other thing that happens is the neutron star in the center is initially
incredibly hot and starts cooling down.
And part of the way it cools down is by producing pairs of neutrinos,
which then also fly out through the star. Some of those interact with the gas,
that's just being flung out and end up creating the enormous explosion that we
see.
The location that this has happened within the galaxies of interest too.
Isn't it? It seems to be in one of the arms of galaxy. Is that normal?
Yeah, I mean, so it's a very massive star.
Massive stars have very short lifetimes, at least by stellar standards.
We're talking about, you know, hundreds of thousands to millions of years,
which really means that they don't move very far from where they were born
before they blow up and most stars form inspire at arms.
So because it hasn't had time to move out of its sort of, uh,
you actually see it blowing up within the spiral alarm where it was.
So most stars are born inspire alarms cause that's where all the gas and the
energy and all the, all the stuff's kicking off, but they don't stay there.
It's not like as the arms swirling around the galaxy, the stars go with them.
No, you should think of spiral, arms as light waves,
which are traveling around the galaxy and they travel around the galaxy at their
speed and the stars travel around the galaxy at their speed.
And they're not the same in most parts of the galaxy. In fact,
for most of the galaxy,
the stars and the guests that make up the galaxy travel faster than the spiral
arms.
And so the way that stars form is that a gas cloud will travel traveling faster
than the spiral arm will sort of catch up with it and overtake it.
But as it passes through the spiral alarm,
it gets compressed by the density wave of the spiral alarm.
And that compression is what triggers the star formation.
And then the hour after the stars are formed the star,
as massive as the supernova, hadn't had time to travel very far.
It sort of started traveling towards the front edge of the spiral alarm,
but it won't have got very far.
And so you'll still see it in the spiral alarm when it blows up.
Okay.
So it's almost like all the gas is being lit up by the arms as the arms
move around and stars form when they light up and then the stars will move at
the speeds that the gas was moving at,
not the speed that the waves were moving out.
Yeah.
So the stars will continue if it was a slightly less massive star that wasn't
destined to explode shortly after forming,
it would continue and continue moving away from the front edge of the spiral
alarm as it travels fast.
Okay. So the sun, for example, moves in and out of spiral alarms,
as it merrily goes around the Milky way, which it's done a few times already,
you know, the sun.
You know,
it takes about what a couple of hundred million years to travel around the Milky
way. And it's been around for billions of years.
So it's gone round the Milky way, tens of times since. Yeah.
But this poor one and M 61, it didn't get far. It hardly got off the ground. No.
It really wasn't. As you know, it's, it's soon as it was born,
basically it blew up at least in sort of Stella terms.
And so actually it really didn't have very much time.
When you travel anywhere. Is the sun currently in or out of a spiral alarm?
I think.
Between at the moment, that's not, uh,
not in a particularly exciting part of the Milky way.
Will we be able to go back into the archive of pictures of M 61 and
find the star that blue, like say that was the one that's where it was.
That was the one that was just about to go and learn anything from that.
I don't know.
This particular case,
but it is something that people are doing more and more often now. Um,
with Hubble space, telescope image quality,
you can actually see the very bright stars that go supernovae as individual
stars before they blew up.
So if there happens to be a picture of the right part of M 61,
then it will be possible to go back. And in fact,
this is one of the ways we learn about the supernova process is by looking at
these progenitors, these stars,
which are going to blow and learning what kind of star it is that that is just,
just before it blows up, how it looks just before it explodes.
Would we be able to go back afterwards when all the light dies down and find the
remnant? See what's left behind probably.
Not in this case. Cause it's almost certainly too faint.
I mean it for supernova 1980 a and the large measure Atlantic cloud.
So very much closer there with really good imaging from Apple space telescope,
we've been able to start studying the remnant that formed behind the explosion.
Um, but this is just so much further away.
I very much doubt we'll be able to see anything once the supernova itself has
failed.
Now, because this has happened during the pandemic lockdown,
I was all excited because this was, you know,
I was going to call this the Corona supernova,
but you've sent me straight a bit.
And apparently these are not particularly rare events.
These things are banging all the time.
They really are. And because,
so this one was discovered with a telescope called the Zwicky transient
facility, which is actually out scanning the skies the entire time.
It covers the entire Northern sky every few nights.
So it was collecting huge amounts of data and we'll find pretty much all the
supernovae that go off sort of within its range. Um, and so that actually,
when it used to be the case, we'd find, you know,
maybe a dozen or so supernovae a year. Um,
but now with all these automated searches out there,
we're finding literally thousands of supernovae and we've actually had to change
the way we named supernovae a bit to make this fit in that, for example,
supernova 1987, eight, it was called that because it was found in 1987,
it was the first one in 1987.
And we used to just work our way through the alphabet.
And then it turned out that actually you, you run out letters of the alphabet.
So then we went into using two letters.
So once you've used all the single letters, then you'd have AA, BAC and so on,
but it turns out now we're finding so many supernovae that even two letters
aren't enough. So now, now we have to go through three sets of the alphabet.
And so this for example was supernova 2020 GAF O um, and I'm sure,
uh, the next few supernovae you've already been found since then.
So actually we sort of it's that the meter's clocking up very quickly on the
names of supernovae.
Is it possible?
Is it ever happened that someone is looking at a galaxy and the supernova goes
off? Like you see the moment it blinks into existence.
You'd have to be very lucky,
but actually there are an awful lot of astronomers out there staring at the sky.
So sooner or later you'd think it probably will happen. Yeah.
That'd be awesome. You should, you should be out there doing that.
Just watch am. 61 is a good candidate.
You're telling me that's a bit of a hotbed for supernovas.
Yeah, it is because, although, so typically you expect an, uh, a galaxy,
you know, like the Milky way or M 61,
you expect maybe one supernova every 50 years, but actually this one has had,
you know, it had one. So it's had one this year, there was another one in 2014,
or at least another couple since 2000. So this one is a real,
real supernova factory at the moment. No one, I think really understands why,
why one galaxy was suddenly produce a whole bunch of supernovae.
I think it really just didn't give them the very short timescale involved.
It has to be just down to chance. Um, but yeah, if you were well,
it depends which way you look at it, right? Maybe you say, well,
M 61 has had its fair share now. So you want to go and look somewhere else, but,
or maybe you want to say, well, you know, M 60 is on a roll.
So maybe we should just keep looking there.
If a supernova went off in aspire alarm and you were in the same
spiral arm, that'd be pretty, that'd be a good site. Wouldn't it?
It would be pretty impressive. So you remember a little while ago, I'll go,
there was a lot of excitement about maybe build use was going to go. Um,
and there you'd have had a supernova that you'd have been able to see during
daytime from the earth, um, which is a relatively nearby star to us.
So yeah, indeed. If you were in the right spiral arm in M 61,
you'd be getting a bit of a show at the moment. Yeah.
Yeah. But you'd be safe. As long as that wasn't your star.
You want to be a reasonable.
Distance away. Cause there are gamma rays and nasty things, but,
but as soon as you get, you know, unless it really is a nearby neighbor,
you're probably fine.
Are you going to keep imaging this and watch it brighten up and fade away?
Or have you got a bit bored with this one now and you're moving on.
I'm going to try it. So this one was called really early.
I think it's still brightening up.
So it'll be interesting to map out his light curve to see how it's light changes
over the coming weeks.
Although I think I'm going to be slightly in the mercy of the weather,
in that the forecast looks cloudy for at least the next week.
Pretty lucky to get this one. They weren't. And you were showing me,
you had to like thread the needle between the trees and the house.
And that that's where it is at the sky and things. Yeah.
It was a tiny little patch of sky. I could. Amen.
So it was M 61 is kind of in the South from here. Um,
and so the South is the direction of my house from the back garden,
which means that actually, unless it's quite high in the South,
you end up looking at my house rather than the object,
but it turns out there's a tiny little patch in my garden where you can just set
up the telescope and see it and sort of next to the chimney bot.
And I got lucky and actually really lucky in that the clouds cleared it just the
right moment for me actually, to be able to capture an image of it.
You'll be able to get like an occultation with the chimney park.
I did. Well, I have actually had things disappear.
I thought I wonder where that's gone and it's because the telescopes tracked in
such a way that the house has got in the way.
Oh, you think you've found this amazing supernova and it's your office window or
something. Yeah.
Well you got to be careful when you start pointing your telescope into bedroom
windows though.
Spiral structure is that when you calculate the procession speed of all these
orbits, you find that they're all the same.
That's how spiral will start to get to generated.
It's in the case where you can have all those ellipses processing at the same
speed and that procession. So if you can think about it,
you can think about the stars going around and then the ellipse itself is
rotating. I've seen I've sold the squeak by the way, you know,
I sold the squeak WD 40, no,
I just crank the seat of the chair back. So I can't lean back there.